welcome to 2021 las vegas lights
uh media day a lot of exciting things
going on
as i like to say the lights are back on
uh you can see the lights at the end of
the tunnel we are incredibly incredibly
excited
to be back here with a full capacity
crowd this saturday it's been 20 months
obviously as it has been for everyone
especially in our community
it has been a it was a very difficult
2020.
i want to say we are my family 100
committed to keeping professional soccer
in las vegas
there was never any doubt even in the
darkest of times and we couldn't be more
excited to be back in 2021.
um i will start with some some sad news
that we announced yesterday right to all
kind of
you can say with a smile on your face
but daddy the llama right uh uh passing
on right she had been a part of the the
club from the very beginning
uh so uh her sister dolly will still be
here on saturday and stay tuned in the
coming weeks uh
as we potentially get dolly some new
friends so stay tuned for that
uh the big news for this season is
obviously the individual here to my left
and the partnership that we've done with
major league soccer's los angeles
football club
i've had a lot of questions about what
is this mean what
what does the future of it mean uh why
why did you do it
and the answer was very simple uh we
wanted to get better
and we knew that we had brought the
world's most popular sport to the
world's most entertaining city here in
las vegas
uh three plus years ago and we knew that
there was an
incredible fan base here that uh one
that we had tapped into but also that
had been here for 30 years that was just
waiting for professional soccer to be
here
and as i looked at the roster from 1
through 18 as i looked at the soccer
operations department from top to bottom
realizing we had to bring in people that
had the expertise to be able to do this
and so through a variety of
conversations prior relationships uh
kicking the tires on a variety of
different ways of how do we structure
the 2021 season
i'll just say publicly again i couldn't
be more proud
excited and thankful to major league
soccer's los angeles football club
uh for partnering with us in this
affiliation it has opened the doors
uh for a variety of ways to resources to
scouting to
uh player access uh that we wouldn't
have we'll talk about one here with with
danny mazzowski here in a few minutes
that we wouldn't be able to have as an
independent team
what the future holds we don't know
right but we i can say here publicly
without any doubt and i believe lafc
would say the same thing
we are committed to finding a way to
make this work we are committed to
working together
we are committed to growing this and you
can't judge any partnership
on a month a couple weeks you look at
this in the in the long term
and we're committed to figuring out uh
to how do we maximize this partnership
and there's just too many
rich resources with our fan base and our
community
and the success that lafc has had in a
very short amount of time
for those who don't know they were in
the finals of the concacaf champions
league and only their fourth year of
existence just a few months ago
so it's incredibly it's incredibly
humbling and exciting for us to be able
to partner with them
uh the other things for the 2021 season
uh the most interesting team in the
world will continue
fun promotions uh we'll have theme
nights throughout the year
obviously in the past we did the golden
knights night we'll do it night this
year with the raiders
uh we've got the 10 000 helicopter cash
drop we've got the world's largest water
balloon fight
uh all of those things and more will
continue uh
you'll continue to see that right and
it's really important for me
that we not just tap into the local
soccer community but we tap into the
local community
and those that may not be as comfortable
with the sport of soccer as familiar
with the sport of soccer we have to
continue to find ways to make sure
that everyone feels welcome here on a
saturday night part of our soccer
fiestas
a key part of that is uh fan engagement
and making sure that we make this
incredibly affordable
i we won in 2019 best of las vegas best
value in las vegas
pro sports and i am committed to winning
that every year for the next
uh you know decade plus we have got to
find a way to make this affordable
especially after the difficulty so many
people in our community went through
last year so we've done a handful of
promotions this year we've partnered
with terrible's gas stations
to do the terrible's 10 tickets we're
doing 10 tickets all summer long as part
of our summer
soccer series and kids everywhere in the
stadium for five dollars
there is now no excuse why anyone in las
vegas whether you are
living in summerlin north las vegas
downtown wherever you live whatever your
social economic status is wherever
however life treated you in 2020
everyone has the ability to afford these
tickets
and i want to see the place full because
of that right that we want to make sure
that this
is the team of the people in the sport
of the people another thing that we've
done we partnered with the castro verdi
law
group uh and incredibly excited about
this new partnership
and one of the things they talked about
is how do we do something big how do we
start this partnership
uh with vegas's back right when we
started to see that vegas was opening
and how do we do something around them
and so they basically as part of their
partnership or they're underwriting 2
000 donated tickets for every home game
in june
to go to frontline workers and we
started talking about what's a frontline
worker right obviously the definition
has become very murky in
in recent years are we using that term
and alex nicastro verdi and his brother
orlando said
frontline workers however someone
defines it themself we're not here to
try and you know tomato tomato tomato
we want anyone who considers themselves
to be a frontline worker to be able to
go to the lights website and to be able
to register for free tickets
uh for them and their family so that is
an incredible thing that we're doing
for 2000 uh individuals for all four
home games in the month of june so i'd
love
honestly my friends in the media if we
can get that word out as much as
possible to say thank you to everyone
who helped las vegas get back
uh obviously we will continue with we
call the coolest seats in sports
uh ten uh poolside seats uh
those will continue this year already
sold out for saturday
and then we've obviously added something
new and exciting i call it the most
coveted compliant seat in all of
professional sports
uh thanks to my friend john barr here to
the left i'll introduce in a second
we'll have what's called toyota row you
all remember unlv
basketball and they had gucci row well
we've got toyota row you can drive your
car if you register with us in advance
you can't just show up right we'll let
you you register in advance
you can drive your toyota any type of
toyota into the
into the field and park on the field you
can watch in your car i'd suggest watch
on top of your car
but this will be the most unique type of
seating that we've had
and again it's a way to not just do our
partnership with toyota but also a way
to
how do we take this old stadium and not
be hamstrung by what cashman field is in
the difficulties of it being an old
stadium but actually embracing it i've
often said
i want this to be a professional bait i
want this to be a professional soccer
what wrigley field in fenway park is
professional baseball
right we want to take the cashman field
in all of his charms
and these are us finding ways to how do
we work with every nook and cranny that
is in this building
and create really fun experiences that
people that may not be hardcore soccer
fans
but are coming to one two three games a
year and making them feel comfortable
and having a fun experience at a very
affordable price
uh the other thing talking about the fan
experience
uh if you've been to our games you know
we love confetti right in year one i'll
be honest we had dinky little
confetti blowers right and if the wind
was blowing the wrong way you wouldn't
even see it
and year two we written rented two you
know big size confetti blowers and the
fans really enjoyed it
well this is what we're gonna do this
year we have bought six industrial grade
confetti blasters double barrel
two footers uh with co2 canisters this
is going to be the most confetti that
you've ever seen
we are going to have fun i've always
said i can't guarantee wins i can't
guarantee goals but i can guarantee that
every single person in this stadium is
going to smile and have a good time
even if you're the grumpiest old man in
the history and you're here for the
other team
you're going to have a fun time uh at
our games and so that is part of the
commitment of not
just being affordable but making sure
that we're having fun um
and then the last thing before i
introduce the the coaching players is i
i want to introduce john barr
and i know this may sound like it's
self-serving and he's your sponsor so
you're bringing them out here
that's not the case right john has been
at every single game from the very
beginning
the finley family has done an enormous
amount not just for local professional
sports and amateur sports but all
different types of
uh community organizations uh
but but obviously 2020 was a difficult
year
right and uh we are very thankful for
anyone who's ever partnered with us
we're thankful for our former partners
but we had an opportunity at the end of
the year of understanding trying to
figure out how are we going to make this
work
how are we going to figure this out and
how we're going to go find a partner
and we knew immediately that we wanted a
hyper local partner we wanted someone
that understood the struggle that our
community went through that understands
our community
and again as we reach out to everyone in
our community whether they're a hardcore
soccer fan or not
that it was something that resonated
with them uh and so john on behalf of
the my family and the entire
organization
i i'd love for you to just say a few
words and just thank you again for
everything
that you've done for las vegas and for
this club this season thank you brett um
i'm kind of honored and humbled um
didn't kind of expect to be sitting here
in this position but i'm glad i am
i want to say that the finley family are
100 behind any activity in this city but
they've
embraced this one because of my love of
soccer and justin's love of soccer
justin
as a lot of you maybe know new brett
actually went brett was orlando yeah
and was involved in an effort to bring
an mls team here
and we're going back six or seven years
ago and he was really near
with obviously everything stacked
against him quite frankly
um the lights is a natural transition
from my perspective being
from where i'm from and and my love of
football
or soccer as a lot of people call it
here and i understand that
um is is kind of only magnified in the
sense that
i love to be involved i mean i enjoy it
and i really have all the faith i'm very
very passionate
um maybe a little over the top at times
to be honest but that's okay
he fits perfectly with us oh yeah there
you go and
you know want to say again finley toyota
the store that
i run personally and everyone involved
from stephanie is my
promotions manager from the finleys
which have been supporting sports quite
frankly in this city for decades i mean
it started
way way back with the unlv and when the
basketball team was obviously
very very popular back in 1990 the
tarkanian
and now we have this opportunity to
transition into what i believe
is a hidden gem i believe that there's
no reason why this
soccer team i'll make sure i say soccer
not football
this soccer team cannot be the best in
the league and go a long long way and
i know we're 100 behind him i know all
of you
feel the same way and i'm really really
looking forward to this season
thank you john thank you so so next it's
my
it's really my distinct honor uh to
introduce the man to my left
uh again as we were evaluating
everything during the off season and
figuring out
uh what do we do from a coaching from a
roster perspective
there were lots of opportunities lots of
discussions and as the conversations
with lafc became more and more
serious and robust and understanding the
full uh
the full resources that could be put
behind an affiliation
john thorington their co-president and
and
oversees all their soccer operations
called me and said
i i think we've got the perfect guy and
this is an individual that i have known
for many many years
uh he grew up in born in illinois grew
up in in southern california
uh went to germany at the age of 20 and
ended up staying with the exact same
team
for 17 straight years took him to the
bundesliga and set the record for the
most the longest continuous term with an
american with one team
in europe uh i'm sure i'm i'm not saying
that as eloquently as i should
uh in 2002 he made the us world cup
roster in 2006
uh unfortunately he was injured in 2002
in 2006 he
made the roster again played significant
minutes and then as we've had some good
j laughs about in 2010 he played every
single minute for the us men's
world cup team while they beat uh john
barr's england so there's a lot of
there's a lot of a lot of history at
this table it felt like a win
and he's known as the mayor of hanover
let's get it right all right
uh and john had indicated that that
steve
is was a coach on the field and he had
the exact same mindset
uh he had worked and played under bob
bradley who's the head coach at lafc
and that there would be a real synergy
of this when i became most impressed
uh with steve is when i realized that he
had already received his highest
coaching
licenses allowed right with the uefa
super a license
which was a real testament that during
his playing career and immediately after
it that he was seeking
uh the highest of licenses and so while
he has coached uh
in germany for a handful of years i'm
incredibly happy to welcome his family
back
here to the united states to leave the
las vegas lights
thank you those kind words it's been a
fantastic transition and i just want to
say you know for all the reasons but
i pointed out earlier that this project
this this organization
was exciting to me about the future i
think it has a very bright future
and uh is the big reasons why i decided
to be part of this
and was ecstatic to be a part of this
um fully knowing that it takes time to
get this running
but the future is bright as we pointed
out earlier
i'm going we are now getting out of this
restricted zone that we've been in for
a long long time which we're excited
about and i think the same should go for
the light soccer team as well so i think
moving forward will be an exciting group
it'll be exciting project
that i am um fully diving into
100 and have been there for a few weeks
now and we're making headway and that's
the most important thing right now so
it's extremely gratifying to finally be
here at home
at cashman and so and i know our players
are excited about tomorrow and
the incredible fans we've already seen
and we know
virtually um but when they'll get a
taste of that tomorrow so we're excited
to be here
saturday we're excited to finally be
here and uh get a feel for that
what this actually feels like and to
give our players that little extra
needed edge to
you know to get our first w yeah
excellent thank you coach
uh next i'll introduce uh the individual
on my far
right uh danny mazzowski uh
i'll i'll share a story that when we
were launching the team in 2017
uh or we announced the team in 2017 and
knew that we'd be starting in 2018
danny born and raised in henderson was a
graduating senior at unlv where he would
go on to be an all-time top five in
goals assists points
minutes everything else that you you
could think of as a striker
uh and making an attempt to try and sign
danny right and saying that that's the
kind of player
that fits the exact profile of what we
want the lights to be
right danny rightfully so right pursued
the the dream of major league soccer
uh got drafted now signed with lafc
uh where he started in the [ __ ]
champions league final just a few months
ago
and he's been loaned to us for this
weekend and i'll just say
this is the type of thing that makes me
so excited about this partnership
right and not to put pressure on on
danny here make make it awkward
but this is the type of a profile of a
player that we wouldn't have access to
otherwise uh so i'm incredibly grateful
again to lafc and this is where i see
the benefits long term really starting
to pay off to be able to have access
where a player like
danny mazzowski born and raised in las
vegas has the ability to train day in
and day out and play major league soccer
minutes but also to continue his
development with the las vegas
lights simultaneously so danny couple
words
yeah it's good i mean it's always a
dream you know to play for your hometown
team so i have an opportunity to do that
i've played twice
two away games so far and this will be
an opportunity to play at home in front
of
friends family on the professional level
so i'm looking forward to it
and talk about uh your time at unlv and
what it means to be
you know how you didn't have
professional soccer when you were
growing up here now you have the lights
and
yeah exactly so yeah i grew up here
played local soccer and then i played
for
the local college team here at unlv and
exactly like you said there was not that
local team professional team here so now
it is here and
it's kind of funny how now it's brought
me back here through lafc so
yeah it's definitely a special feeling
excellent
and then to my immediately right danny
chris ostomo uh
a usl veteran played previously with
orange county
and signed by the lights earlier this
year so you've been here as an opponent
so talk about your excitement to play
here as a home player
yeah i mean personally it's been almost
a year since i played in front of a home
crowd
so i'm definitely excited for the
environment every time we came out here
for away games the environment was
you know as you said muslims from club
um
yeah and i love it i can't wait to play
in front of the fence excellent
so we can take a couple q a and then we
can do one one-on-one but if there's any
questions for the group
brett you mentioned and you keep
mentioning you know it takes time
you know it's a long process you know
the future is bright
and we had you on the show you mentioned
that this is just a one year thing with
the la
fc so you keep talking about the future
and it takes time
what is the future so the the
affiliation is a one-year agreement that
doesn't mean it can't be expanded it
doesn't mean it can't be extended it
can't mean it means it can't go on
in a variety of different ways so we are
i can speak for myself and i believe lac
would say the same thing
we are working as if though this is a
long-term affiliation we are working as
if though
how do we continue to build something
right we're not trying to build
something just for the short term we're
trying to build something
and a foundation here to bring uh
benefits to both organizations
both in the short medium and long term
anything else before we go you still
sound as excited as you were
uh because i got paying customers again
right the party's back on
this the place has been asleep for 20
months is this where you picture the
team to be
when you started the team or
[Music]
so so i i'm going to answer the question
both on the field and off the field
off the field i think we've surpassed 99
of expectations
right that we are in the top five in
attendance that we're averaging over 8
000 fans a game
that the baseball team left this place
for dead there was we didn't know what
the future of cashman field was
and we have brought professional sports
back to kashmir field we have brought a
life and an energy and a
oleola singing and dancing and going and
having fun on saturday nights
so i think that the expectation of the
community back in 2017 when we launched
this at the zappos theater
was this is just another uh alphabet
soup
minor league sport that is going to come
and go right and i think we have
surpassed
all of those expectations off the field
that this is a long-term
uh this is a part of the community for
years and years and decades to come
now i'll also say off the field i don't
think we've even fully scratched the
surface
i think we're going to have 8 000 plus
people here on saturday night and i
think we can go get 15 000.
i think we are just scratching the
surface we have the demographic we have
the size we have las vegas we have a
centralized stadium that is all our own
i think we have sky's the limit so from
my perspective
we have not even come close to being
what we can be as a united stalker
league team
off the field i haven't i haven't hidden
from the fact at all
it's been really disappointing we have
not met expectations
that were set by me and set by the the
fans and that was part of the
uh remit in the off-season is we've got
to go figure out a better way to do this
right and going and partnering with
someone at the lafc that has had
lots of experience and lots of success
in a short amount of time
those are the types of partners that i
want to work with uh to get the soccer
side right
so uh you know it's early in this season
and it's early in our life as
an organization i still think we have an
enormous amount of upside but
the expectation is that both the on and
off field we've just scratched the
surface
coach according to the we all know that
vegas is hunger of
soccer and football and i can speak for
the hispanic community you know what
football means to us and his hunger also
for results
and according to your amazing experience
as a player you know about the pressure
of the teams maybe we don't have a
pressure